هذا المكان هو لتمرين المستجدين من الجنود
الروس على الاطلاق ان كان من الدبابات او
من حتى الاسلحه المتوسطه او الاسلحه
الخفيفه هذه دبابه تمرن عليها الجنود
الروس على الاطلاق واصابه الاهداف في هذه
المواقع المنتشره في مناطق مختلفه ان كان
في باخموت وان كان في او مارنكا في هذه
المقاطعه وهذا الاقليم بالفعل هنا عمليات
التدريب تجري من حولي كما نرى عدد من
الدبابات
والرماء الذين يحاولون التدريب اكثر على
اصابه الاهداف لمصلحه الجيش الروسي في هذا
المكان يتمرن المستجدون من الجيش الروسي
ان كان بعد التعبئه الجزئيه او حتى من
المتطوعين او من تعاقدوا مع الجيش الروسي
هذه القذائف التي تطلق من الاليات الع
الثقيله هنا تملا المكان خلفي هناك دبابات
وايضا في هذه الناحيه دبابات تتمرن على
اطلاق النار كما اننا نشاهد على الارض هذه
قطع ايضا من القذائف هذه كلها هذه قطع
للتدريب يعني الجنود يتدربون على الاطلاق
واصابه الاهداف في ذلك المحور البعيد هناك
اهداف يجب اصابتها من قبل المتمرنين
والمتدربين اما في هذه الناحيه فنرى
هنا المتدربين على الاطلاق من الاسلحه
الوسطى وليست الخفيفه ايضا يتمرنون على
اصابه الاهداف في هذا الموقع التدريبي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاخضر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات